professor hung over your discovery of a
system for control protein degradation
in cells has fundamentally changed our
way of thinking about protein
degradation we can now understand that
molecular level how the cell controls a
number of central biochemical processes
more reactions regulated by ubiquitin
mediated protein degradation or it then
identified every year on behalf of the
Royal Academy of Sciences I wish to
convey to you our warmest
congratulations and I now ask you to
step forward to receive the Nobel Prize
in Chemistry from the hands of His
Majesty the King
and the third laureate in chemistry is
dr. erwin rose